Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
You posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal. Interstellar.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by 99
designs.com which is the largest online
marketplace for graphic design with more
than 850,000 registered designers from
all over the world who
compete for your business.
I've used them for years and I've used
them for some very big projects like the
book cover for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times Bestseller,
translated into at least I
would say 10 1520 languages,
and I used 99 designs because I needed
results and I needed them very quickly.
So here's how it works. You need a logo, a
website, book cover, tee-shirt, car wrap,
whatever.
You put a description on 99 designs.com
then people submit designs and in a week
or less,
you have an original design that you
love or you get 100% of your money back.
So check out 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
you can see some of the projects that
I've done personally and you can also get
a $99 upgrade for free.
This highlights your project,
listing it with a prominent background,
bumping it to the top of the page and on
average this will attract close to 200%
more designs.
It's check out 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim and I think you'll like what you
see.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
boys and girls.
This is a very exhausted Tim Ferriss
and welcome to the Tim Ferriss show.
So glad to have you.
You know,
I am one tired some the bitch right
now and I couldn't be happier about it
because I've been flying
around the country doing
various experiments and I had
the opportunity to go to Palm Beach,
Florida to sit at the home of Tony
Robbins and ask him just about everything
I've ever wanted to ask him. And this
is a very special interview for me.
This is the interview of the conversation
I've wanted to have for 15 years.
Now that I'm back in SF,
gathering myself,
drinking some what appears to be laughing
coyote t I have no idea what's in.
It could be all sorts of drugs,
psilocybin and,
and I'm thrilled to be putting this
out there for you because Tony is a
fascinating character.
For those of you who don't know him,
he has consulted or advised
leaders including Nelson
Mandela, Mikhail Gorbachev,
Margaret Thatcher,
and Mother Teresa.
He's consulted members of two royal
families, the U S congress, US Army,
US marines,
three US presidents including and other
celebrity clients would include names,
you know like Serena Williams, Andre
Agassi, Greg Norman, of course,
the golf legend,
Leonardo Dicaprio and Oprah
Winfrey who calls him super human.
The stat that always just sends my head
spinning is that Tony has developed and
produced five award winning infomercials.
That's of course how a lot of people came
to know of him and these infomercials
have continuously aired on
average every 30 minutes,
24 hours a day, somewhere in
North America since check it out,
April,
1989 it's just Tony TV out there,
24 seven insanity.
This particular conversation is
broken into basically three parts.
The first third of our very long
conversation involves me asking him the
questions I have always been dying to
ask him ever since I first was exposed to
his material. And I explained a lot of the
background, which is kind of hilarious.
Uh, when we get started, the second,
third and the third,
third a wood.
And of course along the way we
talk about his daily routines,
the types of questions that he asks
worldclass performers and so on the ladder
portions of this,
uh,
focus on what Tony has
been researching and,
and really teasing apart and analyzing
for the last several decades,
but especially the last four years.
And that is how do you
master the game of money?
Why is there so much financial illiteracy
and how do you stack the deck so that
you can win?
Because there's a lot of hygiene and
there's a lot of nonsense out there.
How do you actually invest? What do you
do with your money? And it's a huge topic.
But he has interviewed and in fact coached
some of the most unbelievable minds
in the world of finance and investing.
I couldn't believe the list, uh,
including people like Paul Tudor Jones.
Ray Daleo is of course a AA,
a whiz in the world of
hedge funds. And, uh,
the list is unbelievable.
Carl Icahn, David Swensen,
who turned 1,000,000,002,
I think 23 billion for Yale,
some curious characters like mark, Doctor
Doom, favor, uh, sir, John Templeton,
Kyle Bass, who became
very, very famous for, uh,
in effect predicting and shorting,
uh,
the, the subprime crisis, or
at least he made his fortune,
one of his fortunes in, uh,
in, in seeing that through,
through the looking glass.
These are, these are the, the,
the Navy Seals, the, uh,
the, the, the top of the top.
And he has been able to ask them just
about everything that you would want to
ask them.
And a lot of what Tony's going to say
is controversial or counterintuitive and
no doubt you'll disagree with some
of what he says, but I guarantee you,
even if you don't care about investing,
where you think you don't care
about investing. And by the way,
if you've decided not to
think about investing, that
is a decision and investing.
I guarantee that if you listen
to this entire conversation, uh,
which I plan to listen to over and over,
and it's,
it has a lot of information that you
will take away at least one or two things
from Tony that lead you to say,
Holy Shit,
I've never looked at that
aspect of my life that way.
And it'll turn things upside down and
you will walk away with a completely
different Lens through which you
can look at how you're living,
how you're handling your business.
And I think you will find tremendous
value from this single interview.
So I will leave it at that. You
know, I don't want to oversell it.
I will say that for me,
uh,
Tony can be an intimidating guy
just in sheer size. He's a big dude.
And he can actually Paul my entire face.
And now we have a photograph
of that that I'll share,
but I'd get into that in the interview.
Uh,
he's also very seasoned pro and
I have a lot of respect for him.
So it takes me five or 10
minutes, I'd say. Yeah,
let's just say 10 minutes to find my
feet in this interview when we hit our
stride. Then all sorts of gems come out
and there's a lot of good material in the
beginning, but give it some time, be
patient, listen to this whole thing.
It is worth your time.
So without further ado,
I think I've had too much laughing.
Coyote t here's Tony Robbins,
our ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show.
I have a very exciting episode
for you and a very exciting guest,
Mister Tony Robbins. Tony, thank you for
having me in your home of all places.
I'm glad to be home
was lost to have you here as well.
And we have many different topics.
I have many different questions
I'd love to delve into. Of course,
I perhaps unbeknownst to a lot of my fans
have a long history with Tony Robbins,
but not in person.
This is the first,
and for those of you who don't
know some of the background,
when I first graduated from school and
move to silicon valley to chase the
billions that seemed just that
there were being handed out and 99,
uh,
I work in 99,
they were in a way and I
was driving a hand me down,
beat up green minivan from my mom.
The seat's got stolen from
inside or at least the back.
So all my coworkers started harassing
me and calling it the molester immobile
and the job, the company didn't
seem to be a long term fit for me.
And when I was on a road trip at
one point I bought personal power.
May have been personal power too. And I
started listening to, to and from work,
my commute, which is terrible for
those who don't know the bay area,
if you're on 101 in between San Jose NSF,
it's a horrible and ultimately that was
one of the catalysts for me starting my
first company.
So knowing all that you've done,
that really touches me completely cause
you're an inspiring character to me.
Oh not the four work week cause I don't,
I'm looking for the four
hours sleep week stage.
I'd like to be able to pull that
one off. But, but really I think
the way you attack subjects and that's
what you do, you don't look at them,
you go after mastery of them and the
way you experiment and the way you
constantly dig underneath to
find the organizing principles.
I feel a kinship with you and we're in
different stages of life and things like
that.
But I have enormous respect for you and
I don't feel that way about everybody.
I like everybody.
They'll respectively buddy,
you deserve the respect cause you go deep.
Most people are really there.
They're surface level and what they do.
So I'm excited to chat with you and
see what can come out of this group.
Thank you for sure.
And I have of course,
a bunch of self interested questions
that I think will also be interesting to
other folks, hopefully. Uh,
but what's always impressed me about
your entire career and the results that
you've achieved is,
uh,
how far you've been able to take
it in terms of working with, say,
the top 1% of performers
in the world. And, uh,
I read in your, your new book, which
everyone should take a look at.
We'll be delving into it a lot more as
we progressed in the interview. But, uh,
there was a quote from, uh, uh,
Mr Benioff salesforce and who
credits you with effectively,
if there were no Tony Robbins,
there would be no salesforce.com.
It'll be quick told me exaggerated,
but he kind of walked me through this.
It started very much like, dude,
what's up Ma on the freeway?
And you get these, uh, you're able to, uh,
reach such a high caliber of individual
when you meet with such people,
whether they're presidents, athletes
like Serena Williams, Agassi,
actors like Hugh Jackman, whoever it
might be. Uh, you'd Benioff's quote was,
you know,
Tony said to me that the quality of my
life was the quality of my questions.
So what I would be curious to know is
when you meet with these top performers,
where do you start?
What are the questions that you ask them?
Well,
I ask questions when I meet them.
The question I want to ask before
I meet them is who are they?
What are they made of?
What are they after?
What's preventing them from
getting it where their wounds?
What is their deepest pride? Not in a
negative way. Like what are they proud of?
How to find out as much as I can in
advance so that I can be really effective
and efficient when I meet them. When you
meet somebody, just yourself, myself,
the most viable thing
we have is our times.
I tried to be beyond respectful of that,
but also I load my brain with all of
the distinctions I can so that when they
enter into an interaction with someone,
the more engaged I have,
a disproportionate amount of
information, ideas, insights,
wisdom available to me,
and then I can react to what's
really happening in this moment.
So I have what I think in advance and then
I have what the moment shows me and I,
I think a blend of that is really valuable
because in the moment people can show
up in all kinds of ways, right?
You know, somebody could show up.
The meanest person on earth can
be kind in the moment. Yeah.
The kindest person can be very mean
in the moment. So I really, I like to,
I like to grab both those.
And then what I want to do when I meet
them is I want to try and understand what
is it that they really need, not only what
they want, right? Because what you want,
I'm sure you've experienced this. I
have in my life, gotten what you want.
Then you're like, is that
like what the hell? Um,
because what really makes us
fulfilled as human beings,
what we need and there's only so many
needs. So I dig under what the needs are.
I look at what's their model of the world,
how they approach meeting those needs.
And every model has limitations and
challenges. Mine, yours, anybody's.
And so that tells me before I even meet
them where the real challenges and that
I listened for what the surface
challenges and my goal is solve a surface
challenge, but also give them more
than they bargained for software.
The deeper challenge.
And ultimately my goal is that they
have a greater quality of life.
And most of the people I work with
have an extraordinary quality of life.
They may not realize it, they may have
forgotten it ran and lost track of it.
Unless I'm dealing with somebody, which
I also deal with. It was, you know,
coming back from Afghanistan with PTSD
and they got light sensitivity and they
can't sleep at night.
They wake up in cold sweats and they're
shaking or they're talking to me,
that's a different game. Boom. You know,
that something's got to be dealt with.
In a different way. But when you're
talking about peak performers,
their challenges are usually
they're hungry for more, right?
That's the nature of probably
people listening to this.
They're going to listen to Ferris,
they're gonna listen for more like gimme
something beyond what everybody else is
talking about.
And then you're always seeking to try
and find that by not limiting it to
yourself.
Same as myself.
Let's go find whoever's best in these
areas and what's pulled together and let's
find the organizing principles
that quantify this. So
I'm looking to figure out,
you know,
what does that more that they want and
or what is it that's stopping them?
And then I, I go into the experience
and just absorb what's there.
And the combination of the two is
how I'm able to usually get pretty
extraordinary results.
But without the prep,
when most people know about me
at the level of prep on you,
like I can get up and my pinky do six
days in a row without a no turning that
nature at this stage. That's not
intelligence. That's experience.
That's the 40,000 hours, not 10,000
hours. You know, over the years. But, um,
I still prep because I, what I
do is I, and my nervous system,
that knowledge base of what I want
to be able to serve somebody with,
I try to bring that to the surface.
So it's readily available.
It's the difference between emotional
intelligence and what I call emotional
fitness.
Emotional intelligence is the key.
Intelligence is the capability
to deliver something.
Fitness is the readiness to be
able to make that happen. So I,
I'm more interested in being emotionally
fit or being emotionally fit for that
person in the moment.
And when you, when you interact
with people, for instance,
Paul Tudor Jones, yes.
A legendary investor and trader or Agassi
or anyone who's at the peak of their
game and suddenly enters a slump. Yes. Uh,
what are the commonalities, if any, that
you've spotted in the best of the best,
who then sees for a period of
time being the best of the best?
What triggers that type of down slope?
Everyone has got different triggers.
There's some common patterns.
One pattern is so well that
you go beyond your vision and,
uh, you know, it's the astronaut syndrome.
You know, what do you do? Uh, when you've,
you know, you're 31 years old, you
flew to the top of the mountain,
right on top of literally look back
at the earth and saw that picture.
We've all seen photograph come back,
shake the president's hand,
had the ticker tape parade, and okay, now
what you do with the rest of your life.
And so when most of those astronauts,
if you know their histories,
they went through some really
tough times somewhere, alcoholics,
I've got addicted to prescription drugs.
Um, and so, you know, in some cases,
that's why I enter people's
worlds as they've done so well.
They've called the market, you know,
almost hour by hour a week in advance,
and they made more money in a day.
The most people have ever dreamed of
when everybody all was lost their shirt.
And everybody's wanting to know
what to do. Okay, I've done that.
Now what do I do after I've called the
market during the worst day in history?
You know,
most people lose momentum then or they
get distracted cause it's like we need
something to go for it. We all need
what I call a compelling future.
Something that will get us up early,
keep us up late and excite us,
at least the nature of a high performer.
And if you don't have that,
why it feels very dead for those people.
And so, um, you know your presence,
United States.
I remember Bill Clinton's tank to me.
I was with them in Aspen and um,
it was at a fundraiser and he asked me
to come visit him and then he threw me in
the cards to come down the hill with me.
It was on those serene moments
and the lights are flashing,
would come down red mountain
and Aspen if you know the area.
And he sit across from me and it's right
after the blue dress incident to come
out. And uh, he's a Tony and nurses, like,
I'm still so young. He said, you know,
what am I going to do when I leave?
You know,
you know what I'm going
to do in my fifties.
This is the wild thing as if I were you,
I'd get the hell out quick because
he's talking about, you know,
I run a third time if I could
and I was teasing him about it,
but he found a compelling future and
Bill Clinton today as something even
greater in his life that he's going for.
So the slump shows when people outrun
division or the slump can show when they
meet their vision but it's not fulfilling
or the slumps shows when people just
end up developing some patterns
that are unaware of that cost them.
And it can be so in such a small thing
with an athlete that can occur. Um,
and sometimes it shows like a tiger
woods when something happens in their
emotional life and while they try to say,
I'm an athlete here and I'm a human
being over there, they don't separate.
And so what I got to do in
those situations, regardless
of what triggered it,
is I've got to come in and get them
to re anchor in their nervous system.
What made them so effective.
And then you understand Myelin,
the idea that the more you do something,
the more you wire yourself.
It's like the mile end of the
white portion of the brain.
It's almost like using,
if I do something over and over again,
I literally wire myself with this mile
and I'm, it's like having high speed,
you know, cable in there or
whatever the appropriate,
I don't know what it is anymore with
high highspeed really is these days,
the proper term. But versus,
you know, having dialect.
If you do something over and over again
and you can process so much more rapidly.
So I will find what,
where's that Myelin and that person,
what specific pattern we'll hook them
back up again to that part of their brain
where it's effortless to that part of
the brain where they in state and they
don't even think, you know, Andre
Agassi was decades and decades ago.
He'd been number one in the world and
all of a sudden he dropped everyone was
number 19 or something at that stage. It's
like 90, 91, 92, whenever it was. And um,
and nothing worked.
Nothing worked because he kept working
on his swing and he kept working on his
wrist and he was really upset
with his father who was his coach.
There's all these dynamics going,
nobody wants to talk about,
he was actually the point that you've
shared later on that he was thinking about
quitting, you know, playing the game.
This is really early in
his career and you know,
he had gotten injured and Andre was very
frustrated and Brooke shields brought
them to me. They were just
dating at that time and said,
I don't need positive thinking.
And he said, you know what?
You know Tony is not positive thinking
he's going to show you these strategies.
So he comes to me, I sit down with
them and I said, I said, Andre,
he's telling me about how he's doing this.
I said,
think of a time you hit the tennis ball
perfectly. I said, don't think about it.
Go to,
and I got them in state,
got them kind of in that place
where the Myelin is being fired off.
And then I said to him, okay, you feel
that you feel that you got to go, said,
what are you thinking about
your wrist? He says, no. I said,
how the hell would you think you would
ever get back to that peak of I'm
focusing on your wrist,
right?
So I've got to get them back into
the pattern that made it work.
And then oftentimes I've got to help
them resolve some other issue that's
distracting them. That is something
else in their life that's pulling them,
pulling them apart from peak performance.
His story is an amazing one. Uh,
open the autobiography is one of the
things that while I've ever read,
that's why it's such a fantastic book.
Looking at the longevity
of your career, the, the,
the scope and scale of
the Tony Robbins Empire,
so to speak, uh, the s your
endurance has really impressed me.
And so I'm wondering, after
these decades, what are your,
some of your daily routines?
For instance,
what do you typically eat for breakfast
if it's up to you? I have salad and fish.
It's like standard. I'm boring as hell
because I just know it's fuel. Yeah.
I, before I met my wife, we've been
together for more than 15 years. Um,
I was completely anal. I was
like, I hadn't had chocolate.
I had an ice cream and like 15
years. Right. I was just, just crazy.
And then she came into my life
and I forgot. I thought, God,
this woman is incredible. She's a
phlebotomist. So she does the blood,
she's an acupuncturist, she's an
attrition or have these green drinks.
And we had this lunch and that's
where it shorted a hot fudge Sundae.
And I don't what and the hell are you
doing? She goes, live in you basket.
So she loosened my ass up just because
I loved her. So I, I, you know,
she calls it zigging and zagging. We Zig,
zig, zig, and then she's ags are we zag?
Um, and when I was first
with her, I was like,
you're Zagat we were traveling
through Europe. You don't
Roman Italy and, and, uh,
you know, various parts of France, south
of France. And I was like, you know,
you seem to be zagging every day.
And she goes, well, I'm on vacation.
And then later on we were traveling
or something. I said, you know,
the problem is we're always traveling.
So the girl was on vacation,
but she's fit is how great shape.
But I,
I'm fish fishing and salad.
I'm um, I'm uh, you know, uh,
Hi Greens, you know, protein
type of guy, very low carbs. Um,
and my,
but my regimen is I start with something
to strengthen a Joel and nervous system
every fucking day. Aye.
Well, sometimes he's into,
and I'll go in the hot poles and you know,
I'm fortunate I have to have multiple
homes. My home in Sun Valley,
I've natural hot pools
that come out of ground,
just steaming hot and I won't hop poles.
And then I go there in the river.
Here I go into a 57 degree, uh, you know,
plunge pool that I have
and I have one every home.
I have every single bag immediately
upon waking up, waking up,
and we're just like, boom.
Every cell in the body wakes up.
And it's also just like training my
nervous system to rock that. There is no,
I don't give a shit how you feel. This
is how you perform, but so what you do,
even when I'm taking vacation, I do it.
It's just, I don't know. Now I like it.
I like that.
That simple discipline that reminds me
that level of strength and intensity
that's available at any moment. Even if
I'm relaxing, I can bring that up at will.
It's the Mylan. I also have a cryotherapy
unit and all my homes do you have,
you've tried cryotherapy.
You know what it is and then you can,
I can,
I can put the two words together and I'd
probably get my God with all that you
do. You're gonna love this. I'm surprised.
I'm glad I'm teaching Tim Ferriss up.
The, I'm not the first style is
that suck ice mouth suck. Trust me.
I'm on stage and the weekend I do my,
unless at least power than program.
Three days it's 50 hours.
You have been to that.
You got to come as my guest on events.
I would love to,
but I'm going to give you an idea of
people won't sit for a three hour movie
that somebody spent $300 million on
and I got like usher, Oprah going on.
You know, Tony, I love you. But two hours,
most of them are doing 12 hours later,
you know,
Oprah standing on a chair going,
this is the most incredible experience of
my life on Kevin. I, she was like, dude,
I'm in for all three days. But for me
one of those days alone, um, I, you know,
I wear odometer and I'm a fitbit and
it's 26 and a half miles on average. Wow.
We start at eight 30 in the morning.
I finish at one 30 or two
there's one one hour break.
People can vote with their feet
and no one leaves. You know,
there's on average 20 minutes of just
crazy ass standing ovations music stuff
that happens at the end cause people
are just, it's like a rock concert.
It's so much fun. But the wear
and tear of doing, you know,
basic good marathon, half marathon with
the marathon on the weekend back to back,
it's pretty intense. And so over the years
it's like the inflammation in my body,
the demands, I've had to do
everything I can to reduce it.
Nothing has come close to cryotherapy.
Cryotherapy has developed in
Poland and eastern Germany, uh,
and the eastern bloc countries.
And what it does is it uses nitrogen.
So there's no water.
And unlike an ice bath,
what you're doing going to get spasms
and you've got to do, I'm still right,
if you're a boxer, you're a
runner, you're an athlete. Um,
which is what I would do before. Hated
them. There's no, none of that process,
but it reduces your body temperature to
minus two 20 Fahrenheit and you do it
three minutes and it's mind boggling.
In fact,
I have one here and I'll throw you in at
the end if you want. I have a unit here,
I'll do it for you. Um, but what it does
is, and I did about three times a week,
usually when I, when I come back
from an event, I do it, you know,
a couple of days in a row.
And what it does is it takes all the
inflammation out of your body and you know
what inflammation does to every aspect of
body and the breakdown. Um, but it also,
it's sends an emergency
signals to your brain.
It's like resetting your neurological
system cause your brain goes and you're
going to freeze to death. It
sounds terrific. It really isn't.
You'll find out it's not that painful
going in my cold plunge at 57 degrees,
it feels more jolting then this does even,
that's cool.
Even though it's colder because you know,
the fluid of water versus the nitrogen
erectors different. The conductivity.
Exactly. Right. And so, but what happens
is you're nervous has, gets a signal.
It's like everything in your body
connects cause it's like emergency,
our report is a reset
of your nervous system.
You get an explosion of endorphins
in your body, which is really cool.
So you get this natural high,
you feel this physiological transformation
and you get the reduction of
inflammation. What it was
used for originally, it's
for people with arthritis.
And I found my first one because my mother
in law was be calling up and she was
just crying and pain and no
medication was enough for her.
And I hate somebody medicated anyway.
And so I started doing this research and
it just started to come to the u s and
now daily Lakers,
most football teams that gets,
it's spreading like wildfire
amongst the sports teams. Um,
and so that's where it took off.
So I went and got her one and I mean
it took her I think three sessions and
she's out of pain and now there's
none of the day she's in pain.
And now most people can't
afford to go buy a unit,
but there are local places now they're
popping up all over the United States
where athletes go, where people
go, where people go for a juvenile.
It's amazing for the skin. Um, but is
one of the great things. I got it first,
I got it from me and
then now I'm addicted.
So I've got whenever had three minutes.
What type of unit, do you know the, the
actual model and the brand that you use?
Uh, yeah, there's two of them.
The best out there and it's, um,
it was at Java all the junk guy,
Jay Unka I think it is.
I'll get it for you when we go downstairs
and I'll put it in the show notes if
anybody wants to do it. But also
like if you're in La, there's,
there's a place there on, um, well I'll
give to you and putting your notes,
a couple of locations there. There's some
great guys. I'm getting another unit.
This is brand new home. So, um,
and I'm building a, you know,
an additional guest house in
additional size gym and so forth.
I'm going to eat it though.
That's better.
This one is just goes up to your neck and,
but I'm getting one that
encloses you a full room.
And the reason is about 70% of your
nerves receptors are from the neck up.
So when you step into one of those, it's
even more powerful. But other than that,
I don't do much unique or
different with my life. I'm attire.
Uh, the, so you have the,
either the sort of contrast therapy
that you mentioned, the hot, cold,
the cryotherapy. Yes. You have
salad and fish. How far after,
so what does, if you were to kind of
Spec out the first hour of your day?
Well, the first, the first,
every day, um, I do the water,
I'd taken the environment and then the
first thing I do before I do anything
else, my day is I do what I call
priming. Priming to me is, uh,
different than meditating.
I've never been really a meditator per se.
I know the value of it,
but the idea for me of sitting still and
having no thoughts just didn't really
work out for me. It was just a pain
in the ass. And I just thought,
it's not natural. Right? It's like that's
where it works. But when I'm in nature,
I feel that form of meditation.
When I stand on stage and someone
stands up and my brain, it's done.
I don't even know what it is, but person
suicidal, I've never lost a suicide,
for example. And you know, 37 years, knock
on wood, it doesn't mean I won't someday,
but I never have at a thousands.
And we followed up with them.
So it's like there's something
that comes through me and it's,
and it's quite meditative. It's like I
experienced it as a witness, you know,
afterwards. It's one of the most
beautiful gifts in my life. Um,
so I know that meditation, um, but for
me, what timing is, if you want to be,
have a prime life, you've got to be
in a prime state and uh, you know,
weeds grow automatically. I don't give
a damn what it is. And my teacher,
Jim Rone used to say that.
And so when I do is I get up and I do it.
Very simple process.
I do an explosive change in my physiology.
I've done the water
already, right? Cold, hot.
Then I do it with breath because I know,
you know,
all forms of eastern meditation all
understand that the mind is the kite and
breath is the string. So if I want to
move that kite, I moved the breath.
So I have a specific pattern of breathing
that I do. I do 30 of these breaths, um,
and I do them at three sets of 30,
and that creates a profound
physiological difference in my body.
And from that altered state,
I usually listen to some music and um,
and I go for,
I promise myself 10 minutes and I
usually go 30 and I know I do it.
All of this one room is where I do it.
This has got a great vibe.
I'll do this one,
I do it at night.
I usually will go outside cause I love
the wind on my face and I love taking the
elements and so forth. But I do it
multiple places. I'm on the road, I do,
it doesn't matter what day. I always, I do
not miss priming. The reason is I'm not,
you don't get fit by getting lucky.
You don't get fit by working
out for a weekend. You know,
you live your life that way.
Fitness is cause it's becomes
just part of who you are.
So what I do during that time,
because I do three simple things
and I do it minimum 10 minutes,
three minutes of it is just me feeling
getting back inside my body and outside
of my head feeling the earth,
my body and experience and then feeling
totally grateful for three things.
And I make sure one of them is something
very, very simple. The witness, my face,
you know, the reflection, the
clouds that I just saw there.
But I don't just think gratitude,
like I let gratitude fill my soul. Um,
because when you're grateful, as
we all know, there's no anger.
It's possibly angry and grateful
simultaneously when you're,
when you're grateful,
there is no fear.
You can't be fearful and grateful
simultaneously. So it's, it's a,
I think it is one of the most
important power emotions of life.
And also up to me, there's nothing
worse than an angry rich man or woman.
You know, somebody has got
everything and they're pissed off.
I want to try some really high number
then. Yeah, it is because they,
they develop a life that's
based on expectation instead
of appreciation, degrade.
And I tell people,
you want to change your life.
Fascinating trade your expectation for
appreciation that you could have a whole
new life. So everyday I anchored that in
and I do it very deeply and emotionally.
Then the second three minutes I do is
a total focus on feeling a presence of
God, if you will, and will however you
want, a language that for yourself.
But this inner presence coming in and
feeling that heals everything in my body
and my mind, my emotions, my
relationships, and my finances.
I see it as solving anything
that needs to be solved.
I experienced the strengthening of my
gratitude, of my joy, of my strength,
of my conviction and my passion.
And I just let those things
happen spontaneously.
And then I on celebration
and then service, cause my
whole life is about service.
That's it makes me feel alive.
So I flood myself with that
with a breathing pattern
that I take that does the
opposite. It takes the breath down
through my body and back up again.
And then the last three minutes are me
focusing on three things I'm going to
make happen.
My three to thrive and I,
I have some big things that I'll do
and sometimes I'll do things that are
smaller, but I see them,
feel them, experience them.
So it's a really simplistic
process is 10 minutes.
But I come out of it in my power and it
doesn't matter if I had two hours sleep,
I'm now ready. You know, it doesn't, and
I do this even when I have no sleep. I,
that's how committed I am. Um, as I said,
I've always said there's no excuse not
to do 10 minutes if you don't have 10
minutes, you don't have a wife. And
that's how I got myself to do it.
And now that I'd done it,
you know,
20 to 30 minutes is almost always
what it is because it actually feels
extraordinary.
And where can people learn more about
the breathing pattern or can you describe
it?
I'm putting a link online cause they
just started to share this just recently
and I'll get it for you. I don't know
what it was off the top of my head,
but it'll be up shortly,
I think this week.
Okay, awesome. And, uh, I will also
put that in the show notes guys.
So that's just for our
work week.com forward slash
podcast and you'll be able to
find this episode. And,
uh, on the, I have to ask,
what type of music do
you usually listen to?
I have a variety, but for that
meditation, I have one in particular,
which is a oneness meditation that a
friend of mine made it foods from India
that I find really profound as, um, no,
uh, singing in it and things like that.
It's just the sound of a vibration
that's going on and I just love it.
But that's what I'm doing currently.
In the past,
over the years I've used all
kinds of different piece of music,
but I don't use a modern music or pop
music or rock me. I just have to work out,
um, you know, rap. Um, I don't know,
it just feels weird to be doing rap
while you're meditating. But again,
what Steven is, I don't look as meditation
because I look at it as it's priming.
Courage, love, joy. It's priming
gratitude. It's priming strength.
That's primary accomplishment.
It's priming. You know,
when I'm doing my gratitude piece,
I'm doing the circle of who's
closest to me and you know,
circling that out there,
everybody I love and sending that
energy and healing out to them as well.
So to me that's, if you want primetime
life, you got to prime daily.
Uh, well I liked it. I liked
the term priding awesome.
Cause I think that most
people who struggle with
meditation or even an attempt
to, to use meditation are
utilizing it for that purpose.
They're doing it first in the
morning. And uh, you know,
when you said if you don't have
10 minutes, you don't have a life.
That reminded me of something
that Russell Simmons said to me,
which was if you don't have 30 minutes
to meditate, you need three hours.
And I don't always do 30 minutes,
but I do meditate in the morning and
it's been a can very consistent pattern
through, uh, among all of the people that
I've interviewed so far on the podcast,
really practically 100%. Wow.
That's, uh, and of course, uh, we'll,
we'll get to Ray Daleo,
but also very avid meditator.
If he's coming with me to India and a
couple of weeks, that'll be an amazing,
I'm for a week of this experience.
Oh, amazing. Uh, the,
when people hear the name Tony Robbins,
I think many different people have
different assumptions. Were images, uh,
in their,
in their heads.
What are the biggest misconceptions or
the biggest misconception about you?
Oh my God. Many, right to, you know,
when you've been in the culture at
any level, for any period of time,
people put their projections out to
what you are. And then also, you know,
I didn't help myself. I did
infomercials at a time, but you know,
I didn't want to do infomercials.
There's just,
I had these insights and
skillsets and I didn't have it.
If I was a great singer, which I'm clearly
not, there was a distribution channel,
right? I could do that. And if
I wasn't bullshitting myself,
I could rock the world.
But in my world it was write a book,
which most people don't read.
Um, go do some speeches.
So I looked around some of these
silly ass infomercials and I said,
these guys are a disaster.
Tommy.
Lou come be on my boat and watch me get
these women and I'm rich. And I'm like,
oh my God, it's disgusting.
I thought, you know,
if you really did something that was
real and the kind of people I reach,
you know, I don't have to pay for
endorsements, they'll do it. You know,
maybe people start to understand this as
real and maybe to help me reach people.
And it did. It got me to Bill Clinton
and got me Princess Diana got me, I,
he got me a pretty amazing
group of people that stage.
But also you're known by
the company who keeps,
so when you're between spray on hair
and you know, whatever, attention cake,
diamonds, you know, then you, you know,
you're seen as that. And also I talk fast.
I'm a passionate son of a bitch
and so I'm not talking fast.
So what I'm trying to sell,
so I'm talking fast because my
brain functions that speed, right?
That's how my brain goes, slowing it
down. It's just so boring to me. I pray.
The faster I go,
the stronger my brain becomes,
the quicker I can come to solutions.
So, you know, when I'm most excited,
I want to serve people.
It speeds up.
So that helps when you've got a room
of people where you can move the,
modulate that energy.
But when you're seeing somebody on TV
and they look like a crazy son of a bitch
and there's six, seven and they got
hands bigger than your head, you know,
you start going, you
know, who is this guy?
The people that have actually like
yourself where Marc Benioff for President
Clinton or whoever who uh, you
know, actually entered into my work.
Once they enter the my work, they go,
oh my God, this is very different.
So I think most people think
I'm an infomercial guy or
a salesman or a motivator.
I mean I hate the word motivated
is the bane of my existence. Um,
cause I've never been that.
I've never,
I don't believe she could just go pump
yourself up. I believe in intelligence.
I believe see things as they are. If you
can see George, you can't lead, right?
But don't see it worse than it is.
You've got an excuse not to try.
And that's what most people do.
They make it much worse than it is
because they're afraid of failing.
So they come up with a reason
why, a story, why it's not there.
And I don't tolerate that shit. I'm
not the guy that says there's no weeds.
There's no weeds there, isn't
it? I mean the got to go,
let me show what the Goddamn weeds are.
Let's police set of the bitches out right
now and stop bullshitting. Let's do it.
You're not, I'll do it with
you. That's my approach.
I think most people think it's a pump
up approach because you know the media
sees 10,000 people in the room and
they're jumping up and down and you know,
what is this piece?
So that's because I believe that learning,
I believe what I do for people and its
essence when I do events as he cubed them
eat cube is I entertained them first
because people in our society want to be
educated,
but they'd much rather be entertained.
So if I can rock you and get you to
have an experience where you feel fully
alive then, and it didn't matter
who you are, you're, you know,
you're from any stage of life,
any socioeconomic background,
then I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm going to
be able to have your education go deeper.
And then, so that's the second part.
I'll give you the best education,
the best tools. And the third one is
I empower you. You're in this state.
I get you to do things
that you won't forget.
Two things that will be in your body,
do things that create momentum.
So I think the misconception,
at least in my perception is they don't
realize I'm really a strategist. I mean,
I consider you a strategist. I know
you're inspirational, everything else,
but being inspiring as nice. Uh, you know,
it's like motivation is nothing
wrong with it. It's like a warm bath.
You should take one. Are you stink, you
know? But, but, uh, but that's not enough.
It has never been what I've been about.
But you know,
most people in our society
or our interesting day,
it's like if you're looking to
improve yourself, people in our world,
I think that's natural. The average
person is like, what's wrong with you?
I remember I had the, I took a company
public when I was, what, 39 years old.
I had a really wonderful head, 400 million
bucks. I mean, it was extraordinary.
And the man who ran my company had been
the former CEO of CBS, brilliant guy,
brilliant guy, Peter
and Peter. At one point,
while we're in the midst of this company,
he said,
I want to go to Harvard and I want to
take this extension course, you know,
very wealthy guy,
been head of the largest networks in the
world and now heading up my company and
I remember three or four people like,
wow, it's a matter. Why is he doing that?
He lost his edge. He's like,
versus life is growth baby.
If you don't keep growing, you're
going to die. You know? But still,
most people are afraid of the unknown.
They're afraid of, I'm not looking good,
I'm afraid to fail.
And so that creates a challenge.
But so I think the answer question is,
uh, they don't know that I'm a strategist.
They don't know how much I really care.
They have no clue the depth of what I
teach or the diversity of what I teach
subject your body, your mind, your
emotions, relationships, finances, um,
they don't know the real impact or
they don't know who I really work with.
You know,
the assumption is he's taking over a week
people's minds and pumping them up and
giving them all this falls upon
them. That's crazy shit. But,
but I am not here to try to dispel that.
What I try to do is,
the reason I'm still here is the more
people you've touched, the more he reach.
I don't have to do that.
The people who have been to my events
are the greatest people to balance that
out in social media. It's been
really wonderful because people say,
this is what this guy is and 12 other
people go, you've never had an experience.
Let me tell you what this really is about.
And that's really been a wonderful
enhancement to my ability to
reach people as social media.
I just to reiterate something you said
that about inspiration being necessary
but not sufficient.
I think that like you having the label
sort of motivation or motivational
speaker, uh, applied to what
I try to do is very, uh,
frustrating because one of the things
that differentiated you do, Oh yeah,
I didn't know that's just an easy
label to throw. Right. And I was like,
what else would you, it's like,
well, I'm not going to read the book,
so I might as well find a label that
I can understand. Uh, and you know,
I was going to say at least
you get an infomercial,
but at least you weren't selling the
four hour workweek on those infomercials.
You'd have twice the level of how that
you already get. But the, the, the, uh,
the,
the difference in your material because
I w I really wanted to better myself
when I was a hitting some very rough
spots in my first year out of school.
And the difference between say,
personal power and a lot of, uh,
your other material, including
the new book, uh, on,
on money and finance and investing,
which you guys at some point,
I'll try to share some of it with you,
but I have,
I would say probably 20 to 30 printed
pages of notes in Evernote. Well,
just on a, just on a w I s I
still have about 50 pages left,
but it's, it's a big
book. We'll get to that.
I was like giving you a pat on the back.
It's like, oh, another 600 page book.
I know how these go. Uh, uh,
you give very tactical next
steps at the proper time.
So you, you, you do sugarcoat
the medicine a bit by getting,
capturing people's attention and not to
make this Glen, Gary, Glen Ross, you know,
Ai Da,
but you,
you have to have those elements in the
proper sequence so you can't elicit
action from people. That's right. And,
uh, that's something that you've had huge,
uh, you, you've been very
influential on my teaching,
which is how I would view
my writing because of, uh,
that model. And so if you look at say
the four hour workweek is one instance,
the reason that I have these comfort
challenges at the end of each chapter is
because I know I'm going to have big
asks later and I want to condition people
to take action.
And I think that your materials at some
of the best in the world I've ever seen
in any capacity.
I want to say something.
What would you say?
Cause it's really important that
you're one of the few people I've heard
actually notice it. All right. And, and
I've noticed it in your work and I just,
I didn't know it was, it influenced by
me anyway. I'm complimented by that.
But I think you probably would have got
there on your own just by the nature of
your thinking. The dog bit
Johnny, Johnny bit the dog.
Same exact words, different syntax.
Totally different experience.
Especially if you're Johnny and people
don't realize it sometimes when they
think I'm 30 pounds overweight
and I'll never get this.
I've tried everything or I have, you
know, I like, every relationship sucks.
You know, how do I end up with men
or women like this or you know,
this is my third business
and I'm still not there.
And I'll say I was going to happen.
They don't realize that victory is near.
And the reason is it feels like a million
miles away and they're doing the right
things, but at the wrong time or they're
doing the wrong things, you know,
they're doing the right things in the
wrong sequence. You know what I mean?
It's so, there's timing is so
invaluable on some of that.
You and I know we can't control
some of those freaking luck,
but the more you study,
uh, how things grow,
whether it be organizations or human
beings or families or communities, uh,
or the way in which people, you know,
study ontology or study of knowledge,
there's a sequence and it's like,
if I know somebody's phone number
and I dialed the wrong order,
I don't reach him, but I do that same
exact ingredients, the right over,
and that's what people need very often.
Often they just need a slight twist and
they don't know it and they give up.
And so my part of my passion is to
help people find that two millimeters,
you know, that little tiny
shift that changes at all.
One of the people I have these people
that I've coached over the years that are
the best in the world, that
what they do. And, and I,
I'll take on clients who
I think by touching them,
I can touching mass number of people.
That's how I start with Paul
Tutor at 21 years ago. And um,
as turned out really well, this Robin
Hood group growing huge, giving way,
1,000,000,002 weeks this time
and the impact that it's had.
But one of these people was
one of the top to give an idea,
facial surgeons in the world.
And uh,
I remember I went to go see him one
day for one of our sessions and uh, um,
he was late and I'm waiting
and then no problem. I'm busy.
And the nurse says he's going
to be a while. She says,
he said, doctor often said,
why don't you come in and watch?
And I said, wow, love that.
So you know, I get all scrubbed
up, the whole thing. Come in,
he's got rock and roll music in there.
And this guy is like an artist and a
scientist mixed together in the most
powerful blend with a giant heart. And I
go in there, the music's Blair and he's,
Hey Tony, how are you doing? He
goes, watch this. He cuts a lives,
this woman's face off.
And I felt a little speed change
and it was like, uh, you know,
I stayed around for a few
minutes just so you know,
to put up that I can handle this shit.
And I said, you know, I got a few calls,
I got a bank, got the hell out
of there. So I go into his,
off he goes, just use
my office, make a call.
So I'm recovering in his office and
getting to know I'm not a squeamish guy,
but that was, I just
wasn't prepared. Right.
So I'm sitting in his office
and he's entered a stage of
life where, you know, he,
this is a guy that sold to new,
I paid $2 million to fly him over
like 15 years ago, 20 years ago,
to do two of his family's faces.
This is a guy that anybody in
Hollywood who had the money,
he in those days there was nobody but
him the best on earth because he'd
mathematically figured out how to trigger
beauty by what you and I would call
out. He's like, I charge shorthand
for you, an NLP term, right?
Those little triggers in the visual
triggering device that affect kinesthetic
change in human being.
And um,
and so I'm sitting in his desk
and he's got this manuscript.
So I'm curious as the man she be working
on and he wants to finally teach other
surgeons because he's old.
He doesn't want to just himself anymore.
He wants his material not to die.
And he's got a hundred and
maybe 150 pictures in the
most beautiful woman in the
world the last 20 years across culturally
around the world. Stars, movie stars,
different countries.
They've got the same thing for men and
he's got these drawings and he showed
that ironic.
He goes through and he shows that he
makes no more than seven changes ever and
the biggest change,
he makes us two millimeters.
And yet I saw an 84 year old woman
looked like she was an early fifties and
gorgeous. And that's all the changes
that you made on her. I'm telling you,
it's mind boggling. I, for example,
he knows that the measurement
of the pupil of a woman's eyes,
you measured that size and you measure
the distance below your nose to the top
of a woman's life.
It's only for a woman if that measurement
is smaller than the people there.
I had men,
when they look at someone's face are
driven and sexually attracted to her.
If it's a same size of pupil,
there's attraction.
If it's just two millimeters more,
she has an average face.
If it's more than two millimeters more,
her face is what he calls, but ass ugly.
That was a technical term
you used at that point.
But so when I taught women this,
they start measuring their eye.
So he makes this little change and it
creates that puckered feeling that men
don't even know why it's instinctive.
It's just a triggering device
that's instinctual than
me. So he knows the seven,
he knows the two millimeters.
And I was like,
you take somebody 84 50 and
looking pretty damn hot. You know,
maybe not to a 20 year old but
at 30 or 40 or 50 year old.
Certainly it's mind boggling. So I've
always learned it. It's like golf, right?
You know, two millimeters,
different stream, you know,
shanking way over here or putting it on
the green. So that's the whole thing.
Victory is near,
but it got to know that very often
syntax is all that has to change.
There's nothing wrong with you, there's
nothing wrong with the core ingredients.
Got a sequence it differently. Yeah. So
you mentioned a few things. The first,
is that a hand bigger than
someone's head or face?
I think that for everyone listening,
uh,
at some point I would like to see if you
can actually pull my face and I'll put
that out on social media because I'm
pretty sure that you can and I'm sure
everybody would love to see they all,
they're probably a lot of people listening
who don't like me very much and would
like to pull my face. So Tony will
step in for you later. Uh, the,
I'd love for you to mention a little bit
about the new book and just sort of a
very basic overview and then I have a
bunch of specific questions because this
is the first book in 20
years, 20 years, 20 years,
and I've read pretty much everything that
you've put out that I'm aware of. Yes.
And I guess, pardon me? Pardon
me? Thought a few things.
When I saw that this book
was related to two money, uh,
and also referring to it as a game
in some ways. I thought, number one,
what hasn't already been said.
There's so many books,
there's so many books on
money. And I think that, uh,
perhaps undeservedly so I feel like
I understand a lot as it relates to
investing and money. And I've
read David Swensen, I've, I've,
I've read about his allocations. I've
read the annual letters of Warren Buffett.
I read the letters to shareholders from
people like Howard marks or other hedge
fund managers.
I know some of those guys.
I saw a couple of names pop
up that I recognize. And uh,
I was, and you said in the very
beginning of the book, and this is a tea,
I've tried to do stuff like this in
the past. I realize how hard it is.
You try to write a book that the,
the neophyte,
someone who's never taken
their finances seriously,
we'll derive a lot of value from.
And yet at the same time you say even
very sophisticated investors want to be
able to get a lot out of this book.
And I thought to myself, oh boy,
this is really talking a
big game. And, uh, the,
I mean,
the interviews at the end of the book
alone are worth magnitudes of order more
than the book itself. And
you've got Google, you've
got ray Dalio who runs the a,
the,
I believe it's still largest,
largest mutual fund, the bowl, the
largest hedge fund with, uh, Carl Icahn,
who's Time magazine, put them on
the covers, master of the universe.
It's guy that sends out one tweet and
apple goes up 17 billion and in an hour,
right? That's up 50%. I was out and
he was not doing it again today.
I don't know if you saw Carlos
quite a character. Um, yeah, no,
the two things. One coming, what you
said. Um, uh, that's the challenge.
I love when I do my
business mastery programs,
I bring people in from usually
somewhere between 15 and 30 countries.
I translate four or five languages.
They're different financial systems,
but business, the psychology
and the strategies of business,
it's a worldwide game. And um, and so I
bring people in there that are brand new.
They come in like just starting a business
and you've got people in there like
Homax largest home builder in Mexico
is one of my events, you know,
a billion dollar business and I,
they credit me with $750 million
in increased in two years.
I was doubling the business and I take
this chiropractor or this dentists,
you know,
an army of three and so I'm going to
double your business in six months.
So I love that challenge of how do you
hit both and it's not easy to do that
far. I think we pulled it off, pulled
it off primarily because of who I,
it's not me doing the teaching,
it's me going to the best on earth
and getting them some sheets.
Your homie the same thing.
Um, you know, people say,
why don't you write a book in 20 years?
But how you've been doing well,
about every four days I'm on an airplane.
I see a quarter of a million
people a year in 15 countries.
That's what that I'm doing. And I, and
I love, I live for that environment,
the rawness, the alive, every
moment. Something that stage,
you never know who's going to stand up.
You don't know what the challenge is
going to be. I mean, that feels alive.
And also it's just real and it's now,
and if it's not working for can change it.
Who cares when I go to write, cause I
did 20 years ago, I'm sitting still.
I mean that first alone makes me crazy.
And then number two, uh, you know,
you took my, my hands, my music,
my voice, my face, my intensity.
And now I just got written words,
which I clearly amount of skilled that.
But when I concentrated on I am,
but I also go, this is a mortal,
I can't improve this. You know, it's
like once you write the shit, it's done.
So I've avoided it like the plague. And
then also most people don't read, frankly.
It's, and how they read blogs,
you know, it's like most people,
I can see a generation looking at this
book at 600 and what, 30 pages, right?
But it's these seven steps that you
can do a chapter a day and then 30 days
you've got a different financial
life. That's crazy. Like me.
You'll do it in a weekend, you know?
But what's interesting is they'll say,
you know, why don't you put
this in a blog? You know,
why don't you put this infographic?
Mastery doesn't come from an infographic.
What you know, it doesn't mean
shit. What do you do consistently?
And you got to go through stages
of understanding intellectually,
which anybody can do, but you got
to do and you've got to get words.
There's enough emotional intensity,
attach that understanding
that you actually do it.
And then you've got to get
enough consisting of boat
goes and it gets in your
body and art to feed about,
and it becomes who you are.
And those stages of mastery require.
It's like I, I took taekwondo,
I didn't want taekwondo.
I wanted to learn a key though
was that it was a beautiful art.
And I like the idea.
They don't have to hurt somebody.
10 people attack you at once. Then
it's like wonderful. You know?
So I learned some mosquito,
but I had the privilege of being exposed
to grandmaster June Rhee who brought
taekwondo to this country.
And he trained Muhammad Ali and he trained
Bruce Lee and as acupuncture and so
forth.
Amazing history and a beautiful man,
like the most happy human
being you ever meet.
And He loved me and what I did
was touched by it and he said,
would you like to do this?
And I was 2124 so I said, yes,
but I must get my black belt the fastest
time in human history and you must come
travel with me. We will do this every
day. I don't like you're insane. Yeah.
I read your book in two days. It was
like completely say, so he came in,
I finished being off stage at midnight
or 1:00 AM and then I got up to go train
from one to four and then I'd sleep
from four to seven 33 and a half hours,
four hours, sometimes eight. If I could
squeeze it, get up and do my next day.
I did that for nine months.
I did get a black belt legitimately
in the shortest time history,
but I hate it and never
want to do it again.
But I'll never forget I was doing these
moves and it's like she is four in the
morning.
I'm doing the same fricking move.
And I bent over and over and over
again, and I said, mystery. I said,
can we go to the next move? And he said,
grasshopper, this is the next move.
And he started to laugh.
He goes,
the fact that you think this and this is
the same move is why we're still doing
it. I like it, but you know
what? It was really true.
So I'm into mastery.
And so what I,
I really wanted to make sure happen
with people is that we got them to that
place. And, uh, when I went to
Simon, Schuster is a crazy thing.
So I'm doing these events,
I'm loving this.
I'm sure she's been begging me for a
book for decades, a huge contracting.
They bigger and bigger. And I
said, I don't need the money.
I'm not doing it for the money.
So they finally came back and I,
what triggered me is I saw this
documentary called inside job
and that team and did the audio on
it and it went all kinds of awards.
But what's happened if you didn't see it,
I really recommend you see it,
but I do want to prepare you at the end.
You're either extremely pissed off or
you're really depressed depending upon
your personality.
And I was pissed off because they show
how a small number of people basically
put the entire economic world at risk.
And when they put us near imploding,
the punishment for that was to reward
them by putting them in charge of the
recovery,
printing more money,
and then taxing everybody else in
earth and giving their money back.
It's just my,
it's the,
it's the greatest Steve re
that's happened in human history.
And so I thought this is making
the anchors, there's no solution.
And I thought there's gotta be a solution.
I thought, you know what, I got access.
The one thing I'm going to
access, cause I called, you know,
coach Paul for 21 years.
And I mean,
he's never lost money in
21 years in mind boggling.
His companies never lost in 28 years.
I was brought in when he's
having a tough time, tell,
take things to the next level. And
um, I thought, I know these people.
I know this process.
What if I took with the ultra
wealthy not what and brought it in.
So I think I got this great strategy.
You go to Simon Schuster is wanting to
book forever. And the first thing he says,
no. I said, what do you
can't tell me? No. He goes,
Tony Know Jonathan's brilliant
management. The carpet. It's Tony,
you don't want to do this.
He goes,
people are dying for a book on peak
performance for you dying for a buck on
anything but not finding
this. This category is a
dead carcass is what he said.
It's been picked clean. Same things
you're saying right to ironically.
So did the head of the financial division.
He goes, there's nothing new to say.
I said, that's good.
Everybody's attacking.
And same way I'm going to go to
the people that know nothing,
platitudes at the same bs.
He actually offered me a larger advance
to not do a financial book and I said,
look, I'm not doing it for
that. I'm in for this book,
and so now he's really thrilled,
which was really wonderful. In fact,
the head of that division
came back and said, he said,
I really thought the categories dad
and I had the division. He goes,
this is alive,
so I'm real proud of it,
but I think what's great about the book
is there's not a word in there that's
coming from me on the financial side.
I don't tell you my opinion.
Who gives a shit where my opinion is,
I want to write down his opinion,
his own checkbooks. Man. I want
to know a call I can spend.
I want to know what
Mary Callahan Air Dose,
who's head of JP Morgan and manages
two point 3 trillion with a t.
I want to know her opinion when it comes
to the emotional psychological side.
Yeah, that's been my baby for 36
years. Those bins are clearly mine.
I'll stand on them.
So I'm real proud of what it
is and I think anybody who
reads it will be touched.
And I wrote it to empower
readers of all types,
but I also wrote it because I was looking,
thinking about a vehicle for writing
another wrong, in my opinion.
I think the system is clearly,
you know guys, you know,
if you read flyboys or you talked to
Michael Lewis or anybody like him,
they'll describe to you how high
frequency trading today is so extreme.
We've all heard about it,
but it's just so extreme.
It takes 500 milliseconds for you to
click on your, your EEG trade and say,
I want to buy the stock of Apple.
And you got guys that have spent a
quarter of $1 billion to straighten wines,
but you can Chicago,
New York so they can save 1.4 milliseconds
and they're going to trade hundreds,
maybe thousands of times.
They know you're going after apple,
they know what to do and to make money
a little micro profits. One of the,
each of t groups was going to go public
last year. So I had to do their filings.
You know how many losing days they had
in four years and do not one one losing
day in four years. It's front
running. So the system is rigged,
but even though it's rig, you can still
win. That's why I wrote this book.
I want to,
you can still win and here's how to win
and here's the people showing you how to
win. So I wanted to right that wrong.
I wanted people to have an advocate,
but I also am pretty passionate about
taking care of people in society is
forgotten. And I decided initially I
wanted to like raise my game. They,
they cut eight point $7 billion
from food stamps last summer.
Most people don't even notice it.
If he couldn't have every
family who's being supported,
going without food for one week out
of the month for 12 straight months.
And I had been supporting, I've, you know,
my family was fed when I was 11 years old.
I had no food,
family spanking by and
delivered a Turkey and food.
And it was just the delivery
guy changed my life.
It made me believe strangers care.
So I cared about strangers.
I've been paying it forward and I
fed 42 million people in 37 years.
This year I'm going to feed 50
million people. And myself personally,
I'd started with, I'm gonna
advance the book. I'm going to,
I'm going to wait and sell
books and see how it goes.
I'm just going to dance all of
that. I was like, oh, I want,
I don't want to do ten nine
one in 20 million, the 30.
So now I'm doing 50 million
and I'm getting matching funds.
I have feeding America, delivering the
food and I'm getting matching funds,
targeting 100 million
people this year alone.
And then I'm putting a system
in place to sustain that.
So doing this book has been opening
up doors to thinking larger cause when
you're sitting with Carl Icahn and he
goes, yeah, I just closed the deal today.
I made $2 billion,
2 billion the day I was there after
only 18 months of investment where he
putting on an event and I
forget the number you started
with a small number. Um,
and Netflix,
Netflix,
it made it that day and he's now putting
all this money in apple when he does,
you know, does it little tweet and 17
billion of value goes up right away.
Or you're sitting with Kyle Bass who
took 30 million attorney to 2,000,000,002
years in the middle of the
subprime con, you know, a crisis.
Tell me again, I was like holy cow. I
mean I started learning things, switch.
It changes the scale of your thinking.
So I think I'm babbling here cause what
I want people to know is two things. Yes.
I think this truly, if you'll give
yourself the gift of this book,
it's a category breaker but uh,
it'll show you step by step and I go,
where are you, where you want to
be? If you're highly advanced,
you're going to learn out
of the 55 plus say 50,
but it's really 55 plus Nobel
laureate self made billionaires,
hedge fund guys biggest in the world.
I put the 12 biggest in
the book and you know,
I went to these guys with up the promise
of a 45 minute interview and I haven't
told it was three hours. I know how you
function cause I do the same thing. Uh,
but what was really cool,
but it's like you don't get with Carl
and I get down with Carl and the first
thing he does is he throws the video crew
out. It's like, Carl, what's the deal?
I've never met him before. He's
like, no, I thought very girl,
but I just changed my mind. I can, okay.
Uh, how the, well, we'll do the audio. No,
I don't want the audio. No audio.
How am I going to do this interview?
Have to take your pencil and your
pen here, get over here. And he said,
I'll give you 10 minutes. And
you know, now Howard, your
friends and his, you know,
three hours later I'm out,
you know, pictures of he
and his wife then, you know,
and he said,
you got to really,
you've got to wait to help change
this world and you know, and,
and he's doors of the
book and supports it.
So I want people to know that this has
been a four year journey of going to the
smartest people on earth and finding
out the vast majority of them are
incredibly genuine in wanting
the average person to do well.
They just didn't think there was
anybody who could translate it.
And when he saw that,
I could,
and I can pitch and catch with them
because I do 18 hours of prep before I sit
down with Ray Dalio.
Uh,
they will want to share things that
they've never shared before. And later on,
maybe we can talk about what I learned
from Ray. Dahlia was pretty amazing.
Oh yeah,
no,
I do want to talk about
ray and fascinating guy.
I mean, I'm, I'm so fascinated with
the entire world. I mean, whether it's,
and there's so many different breed and
so this is something that I want to talk
about,
but you have say the Paul Tudor Jones
for those who probably haven't ever seen
and very old film,
I think it's available,
like bootleg VHS called the trader
is an amazing old documentary.
You can find it. Uh, but you can
see his style versus say, you know,
the high frequency guys or a renaissance.
Yes.
All Phd is right outside of Wall
Street. And then, and then you have the,
the, the, the Ray Dalio types and uh,
and all things in common. If you look,
so different strategies. If it's summer,
let's,
let's shake the tree of the corporate
guys and make sure we get more value out
of it. Right. Carl, you know, and,
and some guys are like, Templeton,
I got to interview multiple times for
he died. It's like, wait for the blood.
Wedding, flooding the streets.
That's what you're on the streets.
But it's like when maximum pessimism hits,
that's when you make all your money.
That's what he did. And then
there's the guys like Bogle witches.
It's the index baby. And these days, even
Warren Buffet, it's the index baby. Um,
so the whole approaches,
but what's in common I think is I tell
you four things I saw and stood out and
one is overly simplistic.
And that's why people don't pay
attention to it with these guys.
Pay attention to it.
They don't lose half.
The Keke awakening is not
losing and they are obsessed.
Every single one is obsessed
and not losing money. I mean,
a level of obsession that's mind boggling.
And it isn't just these investors.
You know, Richard Branson
for example, you know,
people see Richard and he's such
an outgoing, playful, crazy guides,
kind of little bird.
And that's some areas.
But when it comes to athletics and taking
on challenges, he's out in the world.
But you know,
his first question every
business is what's the downside
and how you protect it,
right? Like when he did his piece
with virgin, I mean that's a big risk.
Going to start an airline.
He went to Boeing and negotiated a deal.
They could send the planes back and it
didn't work out and he wasn't liable.
That's the wobblies guys think out.
So they look to see how do I not lose
money first because the average person has
no clue if I lose 50%
in 2008 well guess what?
You're going to make 100% to get even not
50% because your principal's gone down
so much.
And it's like people don't understand
you lose 60% it's 200% to get even.
And so the average person,
you know,
lives in a world where they try not to
lose money, but they're not obsessed.
He's got upset seconding.
They all have in common.
Every single one of them is obsessed
with asymmetrical risk reward,
which is a big word.
It simply means they're looking at you
the least amount of risk to get the
maximum amount of upside. And that's what
they live for. So I'll give an example.
Paul tutors,
when I first went to do the turnaround,
when Paul's having some challenging times,
we've broken his leg.
You don't think about this,
he did better than anybody in history
of the world during the biggest stock
market drop in history, literally.
And then he went to the mountain,
he went to the moon. Now what? And so
we lost a bit of the edge and you know,
got involved in other things and so forth.
And now he's got a broken leg.
He's not going to the office. I got
to come inside and go watch that film.
That's the first thing I did.
I went white tennis shoes.
I wanted to go see everything about him,
study his physiology,
the way he used to move,
cause this guy's not moving at all.
What his face was like, how
we breathe, tone of his voice.
What were the physical strategies,
what were the psychological strategy or
the financial strategies. I got to go,
you know,
to Druckenmiller and sorrows.
The we're gonna access to
back then was unbelievable.
See what was he like then to put the
plan together to do this turnaround.
And when I started making those shifts
in him and you could see the shift
happened immediately,
it got really exciting.
I got hooked on what was going to happen.
So as I and I did the same process,
basically that's what I've been triggered.
I'm think about doing things.
Once I did the same process
during these interviews,
I didn't just look at the trading
strategies. I looked at the psychology,
what set it up,
but here's what I found with Paul to the
very beginning and and background trap.
When he's done his best,
he made sure every single trade
had what he called a five to one.
That means if he was
going to risk a dollar,
he wasn't about to risk unless he was
certain he was going to make five.
Now you're not always right,
so guess what?
If I risk a dollar to
make five and I'm wrong,
I can rescue another dog I still make for,
I can be wrong.
Four times out of five
it's still breakeven.
Even their secret is not that they don't,
they're not wrong.
If they set themself up where they
risk small amounts for big rewards
proportionally Po, you know he's
right, one out of three times,
he's still makes 20% so the average person
was a dollar trying to make how much
dollar? 10 Buck? 10 if
I could get 10% wow,
my dollar right of 20%
would be unbelievable. How
often could you be wrong?
Not very often. Not at all, right? You're
in the hole. You're starting from the,
and they got to build back up,
so they're a snicker where it's like,
I was with Kyle Bass and Kyle Bass risked.
Check this out in the middle
of the subprime crisis,
he made $2 billion out of 30 million
because he risked for every sixth sense.
He risked. He had an upset of a
dollar 6 cents for a hundred well,
you give me wrong 15 times and you're
still okay in that area. I mean,
he was brilliant to figure it
out. He's a genius. Figured out,
but that risk reward is why it is. He
showed his kids, he talked. I said,
how do I teach us the average
investors? And he said that, well,
you could teach the way I taught my kids.
And I said, how'd you do that? He goes,
we bought Nichols. I said, what do you
mean he bought Nichols? He said, well,
I did research. I have this
question. That's another
thing that all these guys do.
They ask a better question and we talked
about they get better answers, right?
Then a quality question, better
quality answer. What's wrong with me?
You'll come up with stuff.
How do I make this happen no matter what,
they'll come up with different answers.
So his question was, we're in the world,
is there a riskless
trade with total upside?
And he started looking around and he said,
I'm worried about inflation.
So he decided, well, Gosh, of all the
currencies in the world, uh, Nicole,
when it's made up today, it's not
made mostly of Nicole, by the way,
he said it's costing the US government
nine and a half cents to make a nickel.
That's how our government functions.
It has been almost 10 cents to make
something worth half as much, right?
Depending on plant. It's the perfect
point. So he said, but you know what,
just the actual material value,
right? It's 6.8 or whatever it was,
six something, six and a half a
cup for round numbers. So he said,
if I buy a nickel,
it's never going less than a nickel.
How she believed US government's gone.
So I've got something that
never goes down in value.
So I got a guaranteed return, you
know, I'm not gonna lose my principal,
but they won. It's worth 36%
more than the, of bought it.
How many investments can you have? 100%
guarantee of no loss. And if 36% I said,
yeah, but that's smelt value. And I saw
they passed a law a few years ago. Uh,
Charlie rangle over was the one that
pushed it through. And he goes, yeah,
but Tony said, that doesn't matter.
He's, let me tell you why. He said,
look at Penney's when they changed it
from pure copper to 10 and all things,
they changed. What happened to the old
pennies? There's a scarcity of them.
And now a penny from those days there
were two sets. It's 100% more valuable.
So he said that at some
point the government cannot
continue to do something.
It costs twice as much. Some point
they'll make a change in the materials.
And then all of these nickels worth
the unbelievable amounts. So he said,
I just showed my kids,
here's a risk.
You need to look different
than everybody else.
Don't think I have to take huge
risks for huge award thing.
How do I take no risk
and get huge rewards?
And because you asked that question
continuously and you believe in answer,
you get it. So you know I, he said,
listen, if I could put my introvert,
my entire wealth and males right, that I
do, and I said, you're insane. It goes,
I am insane, but it's the best
possible fundamental investment.
He started telling me how to do it.
He bought 40 million Nichols. Wow.
He has 40 million.
Nicole fills up a room bigger this right.
That'd be on the ground floor.
And he got his kids dragging him
yet I was laughing and having fun.
If you have this like
their little treasure,
he can legitimately do like the scrooge
McDuck backstroke pull full of nickels,
nickels. So that's asymmetrical will give
you one more and I'll shut the hell up.
You're asking me that,
what you're told me the differences I
want you to know there are differences.
We can spend hours and
hours the differences,
but when it thinks
useful is what's a wine,
because then give something universal
that can be applied. Absolutely.
The other one for them is they absolutely
beyond a shadow of a doubt know
they're going to be wrong.
You will come these talking heads on
television and people screaming you and
hidden bells and telling you what
to buy and the right, right, right.
The best on earth, the right values,
right. The pebbles, the, you know,
I don't give it, who are you talking
about? You want to look at Carl Icahn.
They all know they're going to be wrong,
so they set up an asset location
system that will make them successful.
They all agree. Acid allocation is
the single most important investment.
There wasn't one person
in terms of your vehicle,
but it wasn't most important thing.
No matter how they attacked it.
Asset allocation was the element
there and the last one is they are,
they're lifelong learners. I mean, these
people aren't machines like you like me,
like Peter, like most of the
people you and I share as friends.
They just are obsessed with knowing
more now because the more they know,
the more they realize what they didn't
know and then they apply that and they go
to another level and every time you think
you're the best you can be in anything
in life, your body or motion,
Spirit, your finances,
there's always another level
and these guys live by it.
And then the last one that I thought
almost all of them are real givers. Um,
not just give her some surface like
money givers and that's wonderful. Um,
but really passionate about giving and
did showed up once they saw what I was
doing was legitimate.
It was really real that,
I mean then they're opening up three
hours of their time with something.
I think these guys will never go.
Oh yeah.
I mean their hours are worth a
lot to say. Wow. I same Elise,
thank you for supporting the sponsors
of this show. I've used them.
I like them and I think you will too.
99 designs.com. Forward slash. Tim,
it's the world's largest
marketplace of graphic designers.
You can see the projects that I've put up,
the competitions that I've spearheaded,
including the book cover
of the four hour body,
and you can also get a
$99 upgrade for free,
so check it out@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash 10 of course you can
subscribe to this show on iTunes.
You can also find every other
episode in the show notes,
links from this episode@forourblog.com
that's f o u r h o U R B l o g.com and
just click on podcasts.
There's all sorts of other cool stuff
including my interactions with people like
Warren Buffet,
Mike Shinoda of Lincoln Park.
The list goes on and on and on
and I would love your feedback.
Let me know what you thought of this show
or you'd like to hear on the show next
and any other thoughts really,
you can find me at Twitter at at t Ferris,
that's twitter.com forward slash t f e
R R I s s and on facebook@facebook.com
forward slash Tim Ferriss with two
r's and two s's. Until next time.
Thank you for listening.